hola raúl si no los tenemos que tomar
con calma como hemos dicho todos estos
días porque sabemos que las
negociaciones pueden tomar muchos meses
pero el protagonismo ahora está
justamente de liberales y de ecologistas
que son los grandes deseados por los dos
vencedores de estas elecciones en el
partido socialdemócrata y la democracia
cristiana de hecho ayer ambos líderes
estuvieron hablando a la prensa y
poniendo sus líneas rojas para los
liberales cuál es la línea roja que no
hay aumento de impuestos y que no haya
aumento de la deuda pública pero para
los ecologistas es todo lo contrario
ellos quieren comenzar a invertir
renovación del país y obviamente el
calentamiento global en el centro de sus
prioridades también el líder de los
liberales christian lindner dijo ayer
que él quería el ministerio de economía
pero ahí también hay un problema porque
el colíder de los ecologistas recordemos
anna-lena barba era la candidata pero
hay otro líder que es robert sabe que él
quiere también ese ministerio así que
bueno ellos son obviamente hoy los
protagonistas en la prensa por ejemplo
la foto de ambos líderes porque ellos
tienen ahora la pelota en su campo por
otro lado el líder de la cdu sigue
insistiendo en que puede formar gobierno
pero también este empecinamiento es
según algunos una forma de no renunciar
a su hijo del partido pues por ejemplo
en el año 1998 cuando helmut kohl perdió
las elecciones siendo un demócrata
cristiano cierto el renunció al día
siguiente es el peor resultado
recordemos el que ha obtenido army light
de la historia de la cdu pero él sigue
insistiendo en que puede formar gobierno
y ayer decía que ningún partido en
realidad y eso en eso no se equivoca ha
recibido un apoyo muy fuerte del
electorado alemán por lo tanto todos
tienen posibilidad de formar gobierno y
por eso él sigue allí optando en su caso
por esa coalición jamaica